hey guys justin here with the gamespot
news update the PlayStation Blog has
just confirmed that there are a ton of
indie titles coming to the PlayStation 4
soon spelunky will include 1080p
graphics the ability to upload replace
to the leaderboards and more social
features in the daily challenge if you
already own the game on ps3 or Vita
you'll automatically own it on ps4 as
well the multiplayer fencing game need
hog is coming with a new feature that
will indicate your fencers color on the
controller's light bar axiom verge a
sci-fi side scroller is also coming to
Vita as well as ps4 source is an
adventure game reminiscent of Metroid
and Castlevania the stylish strategy
game skulls of the Shogun will be
getting a new single-player episode a
new tanuki monk character and a new
progression system chasm is a
procedurally generated RPG platformer
drifter also coming to Vita is an
open-world sandbox space trading game
chariot is a co-op adventure platformer
where you maneuver a chariot through
underground levels escape goat too is a
creative platformer featuring the most
popular farm animal in gaming apathy on
looks like Greek pottery ironclad
tactics combines card games the American
Civil War and robots star wall just the
tip is an extremely fun multiplayer game
hitting star wall versus star wall and
Jamestown pluses the Jamestown vertical
shooter with a bunch of extras for even
more gaming news stay tuned to gamespot
com
you